who's this cutie
sami sami camille what's the man mr man
you missed a man
say hi hi
this is called instagram live hi weirdos
hey stop it hi vloggers if you're
watching this i hate you hey saint i'm
[ __ ] hey hey look what you're
teaching me kim kardashian's sons saint
and song crash her instagram live and
cause a little bit of trouble okay guys
[Music]
hello my little brother's hurting me oh
he's not hurting you boys will be boys
right kim you just gotta roll with it on
tuesday kim attempted to include her
sons in her instagram live on their way
to the tonight show look this is called
going live on instagram
instagram
instagram all right guys we are pulling
up to
jimmy fallon
sami camille what's the man mr man
missed a man
say hi this is called instagram live hi
weirdos hey stop it hi vloggers if
you're watching this i hate you hey it's
st i'm watching hey hey look what you're
teaching him yeah saint totally back
talks his mama and quickly tries to
redeem himself and his little bro
this is a good boy this is a good one
okay guys we are in pulling in the
parking lot
in new york in new york we've been
sitting here
look at that toy store that's something
you're not going to see because you
are saying bad things no i'm going to
get some pokemon i can get pokemon yeah
we want some pokemon you don't even know
what pokemon is song and just when you
think things are going smoothly it
becomes pure chaos again can i get a
kiss
can i get a kiss
oh okay
[Music]
oh but the madness didn't stop there
it's so crazy during kim's appearance on
the tonight show the little ones
couldn't keep quiet i know everything i
know oh my gosh yeah so i've been
schooled but i really didn't know uh i'm
not i'm hearing kids guys can you stop
this is like your first time at work
with me you're kidding me
your kids are right there um
well that is
and it happened more than once so she
wanted to have a spooky wilderness
themed
birthday party so i took them out
camping in the wilderness guys seriously
you've got it you've got to go
you don't have you don't have to they
can go back if you don't feel like they
got here it's fine okay they saw me left
yeah
he was being left after that the kids
got the memo and kept quiet but even
when they're a little out of line kim
loves being a mama i think after having
kids it just is such a life changer our
life is so different i feel like this is
when life really
begins
and while we've seen kim's daughters
north of chicago on her page a lot we're
hoping to see more cute moments with
saint and song can i get a kiss
[Music]
you